皆さん line スタンプ何使ってますかまあすごいね今いろんな種類の line
スタンプがあると思うんですけども僕が再現使っているのはこちらあのにょいうワン
ちゃんというスタンプでございます
多感なワンちゃんのスタンプです微妙な肝臓表したいときにどうぞ
ブック購入タンク好きなんですけどどうですこのレパートリーなるほどいいねぇイヤー
じゃーん
いやああああっっっ
まあ音もううーん
うーんわかりづらい
だがそれがいいんですそこの咲く何かと言いますと全く意味がわからないといろんな人
に使ってきたんですけどもみなさんやっぱちょっとイラッとしてますねこの絶命な
スタント北使ってるんですけれどもそれをですねツイッターでとの使っててつぶやい
たらとあるアカウントか
てきていましたはいこちら謎の犬 id が@謎ドック
説明文にはワンマンと書いてありますフォロバが1人
僕ですねで何か452もフォローワーがありますこのアカウント
郊外僕が正体を暴いていこうと思います何全くわかんないっすよなんでできたんだろ
最初僕がふざけてない
版は謎の犬から来たんで大と思って返信したんだったかな
そうだ大字北にバーンと言ってきたんで僕がはだった編集を送り返すとまあまあ通知
めっちゃきて怖かったと怯えているご様子です謎のいいねまぁそこからこう定期的に僕
に文書を送るようになったんですけど基本的にでブロワーファン歯科に行きません
たまに自分で薬を入れて僕に文書を送りつけてくるという感じですねもうんとかこう
いう形で基本的には
バーンとは大しか言えないタイプなんですけどもオバマとバーンめちゃくちゃ送って
くるですよ本当にほとんどすべてまあまあと繰り返してくるんですけども
お手をすると最近やっとバーブと言いながらこう画像も載せてくるようになってね
表情表すようにもなってきましたこれ誰がやってるのかなと僕思いましてやぁやすい
じゃないですか普通に普通に怪しいです僕はこの院スタッフ
ic すぎでひょっとしたらその具現化してしまってこのだとないんでどすたーる打つ
台に魂が好評言ってしまってとと白スタンプの犬が正しい
それはないわすいませんそれはないです損害で謎の犬の中身の人をちょっと女確かめて
いきたいとおもいます
ペアたセレナず5と喋っていきましょうまずは生成パンツならまだ大勢パンツでマー
マンとぐっとみましょうこの後の出方次第だな
ポンプ
ん
マーク時間ではうわーこの時間に謎内でがヴィンターやってるかやってないかという
ポイントですから
バートはて方ですねどこまでこのバンバンキャロッツんですか方また dm になると
ば版喋り出すか
[音楽]
ん
謎のいねえ
あれから謎の夢からの変じゃなかったんですけどもふと見たら返事が返ってきており
ました
は版今働いておりましたすみません1
働いてるんですね働いてるって事がわかったので謎のインドがきっと社会人の雪があり
ますでさっきすぐこんばんはって送ったら
こんばんワンちょっとびっくりしてる様子ですあああの神と言ってきましたから
ちょっといろいろ話してみましょうかあぁ今何してますかといったら youtube
見せましたとなかなかいい中火のいるんですな
関心ですありがとう
ございますまあまあちょっと本人の中身富豪の早いのでもうちょっとちょっと質問して
います
まあ食べ物でだいたいその人のイメージというかそういうのは分かるんで何だ何何を何
を好きなんだろう
5年間犬なぜ犬らしいなんか謎の印ですからねぇ
これ動画です体が効いてなかったらけっこうこれの反応によりますね
ね行動にしたいからひょっとしたら謎の犬なぁカードを作ったって人もいますからこれ
でちょっといや nest が入ったら本物だよ
マーズがいなく
待ってましたが全然大丈夫ですよここ一番で喜んでるんだ操作をプライベートな質問に
迫っていきましょうか結局私の皆さんもこの中身の人が誰かどんな人がやっているのか
知りたいと思うのでそこら辺はちょっと攻めていきましょうか
ないてらっしゃる3節なんてあなたの正体はわきますよ
何た何のないにではないですね帰ってきてるそう
そんなわけないじゃないですか怪しいなここはちょっと同種っぽく威嚇していきます
同じ犬ということがわかればまた
対応が変わってくるかもしれない
わー author 国家ですね search 大きく鷹山まずは年齢からいき
ましょう皆さんは何歳なのですか
これで謎の家さんの年齢がわかりますね
さあ何で返すか
人間的には18
結構若いな18で働いていたということはバイトしてるかもう働き出しているから
どっちからオスカメ子かは気になるところですね
母数か方法法則はやっぱりちょっと愛甲別所ですね
18歳の雄ですねちょっとここでバスと聞いてみましょう
始めたのには多分皆さん理由があると思うので
なぜこの謎の犬さんはまあ犬シロ人間にしろ
通して twitter を始めたかをちょっと聞いてみたいところはあるさあ道具
うやることがなかったもんでまさかこんなことになるとはやることがなかったみたい
です方法
高校生みたいですね彼はなるほどなるほど
まさか受験生じゃないだろうね x 反対ってことは受験生じゃない分
一応終わってます多いつか出たのでこれでもあれだね
なんかその偽アカウントとかじゃなくて本当にただ楽しんでるだけだ
んで僕は全然こいないいと思いますこれからは謎の湯で通して頑張ってくれ応援してる
よって最後に視聴者さんに一言あればぜひ一つ上げという言葉です
強ネクタイああ
[音楽]
me
バッハ